this is a production of cornell
university
this is the scott henry training system
and we've probably talked about this in
class
it's what we call a dynamic training
system which means we have to do an
adjustment during the growing season
so we've got uh four chains one two
three four
and
what we do is we position the lower tier
downwards so when we looked at the
double geo we've got four killings but
everything grows up and the scott
henry's system the top grows up and you
can actually see this is what a machine
harvested
or mechanically harvested block looks
like so you can see what's left here uh
in terms of where the fruit was
so we had a fruiting zone up at the top
here
then we have a bit of a space and then
we have a lower fruiting zone here
and these shoots are actually positioned
downwards
so that we come along just after berry
set
and flip this wire downwards so they're
growing up then we flip it down and pull
the shoots down
as a result the growth along the bottom
isn't always very good
but it gives us this space here in the
training system that allows for more
light and more airflow
so this is something growers don't
always like it's extra work but the
studies that have been done usually show
that this can improve yield while either
maintaining or improving fruit
composition so it's a really good system
that many growers need to consider using
so i'm going to prune this scott henry
system and get us down to four canes two
that go out here
and two that grow out here
so i was just looking at this uh to
figure out what i was going to use and
remember i don't want to use bull wood
so bullwood is something that's built in
diameter it has long spaces or long
internodes uh between the buds
and so i looked at at this shoot right
here
and i thought oh that's bullwood i'm not
going to use that so i thought okay
where am i going to cut this out and i
went to look and then i realized hold on
it's not from this vine
it comes up as if it is let's pull this
out because
it's crazy long
okay
so this is how long it is and it's not
even from this vine
and it's not from the neighboring vine
it actually comes from two vines over
so this is an absolutely crazy amount of
bull wood i mean this has got to be
15 feet or something like that
this is what you do not want to see
in your vineyard
so i'm getting rid of that
okay so i'm going to cut away some of
the extra stuff so that we can figure
out exactly what we're going to use here
so we'll start with the lower tier first
and remember
we want to keep everything close to the
head so that we don't get a a space
where we're not going to have fruit
production
so i've got a can here that's kind of
gray at the bottom so i think that's
probably not going to be very good so
that's really not a good option for me
these ones here are too far out
so we'll cut those right out of there
uh and that leaves this one here
it's a little bit gray so i'm gonna see
what else we have for the bottom tier
that's too low
not useful
that would be a possibility but it's a
little bit big with long internodes so
i'm not going to use that either
so to simplify here we're going to cut
this out too
so looking at what we have
here i'm actually seeing
a possibility for a cane that could go
along this wire
so if i stretch this one out i've got
all of these buttons along here that are
going to produce shoots
whereas if i use this one i'm going to
have this space here that doesn't have
any shoots
so i think i'll use this claim to go in
this
direction and then along this side
this one doesn't look too bad i'd like
it to be a little more brown it's a
little gray through there
but it might be my best bet for laying
out in that direction
so i'm going to use these two canes so
i'll get rid of this
cut this out of the way
and that's going to be my first clean
along here
so i'll wrap it for now we'd come back
with these cane ties that we use and
actually tie these into place a little
bit later
in the spring
so for uh here i think i'm gonna use
this cane
it's a little gray towards the end but
uh we're running into this vine anyway
so then what i can do
is get rid of this whole thing through
here
because i'm not gonna use anything that
comes from it so
i'm going to cut this out
and i think i'll cut it right down it
actually it looks like it's a root
sucker anyway because here is our graft
union here's the bulge
and it's actually not coming from the
graft union
so this is a mistake someone should
never have tied this one up anyway
because
it could be root stock material rather
than than fruit and uh fruiting wood or
cyan would
so
we've got a kind that goes this way
cut some of this extra stuff out
and a plane that ties out in this
direction here let me get rid of our old
one
this comes from the neighboring vine i'm
going to cut that back
so
that comes from the neighboring vine as
well
so there's our two cones
for our lower tier
upper tier uh it looks like we've got a
little bit more choice here
either of these two shoots right here
are probably a possibility this one
might lay out there as well
so i'll cut the rest of this older clean
off
to get it out of the way so i can see
what i've got
so
there we go so that's cleared out of the
way
and along here i know i'm not going to
use anything past this one
so i'll get that out of the way as well
and it's tied in there pretty good with
a cane tie that i'm going to pull off
there's a lot of vigor in this block
which is why we have some overlap from
neighboring uh vines here because we
needed more space to lay out more buds
cut this out
so this allows me to look at what's
really good here
uh this is nice nice brown wood but it's
just too big in diameter definitely some
bull wood there
that's pretty useless so we'll cut that
right out of there
uh i just damaged that chain a little
bit as i pulled the other piece out so
it's probably still gonna be okay so
that's a good option still
that is probably an even better option
it's a little bit smaller in diameter
and i don't have to worry about uh that
little piece of bark i just pulled off
so i'm going to keep that one
it's from the neighboring vine
as is this
okay so this one
and i just hit myself in the face with a
cane
this one we're going to tie out this way
and then we've got this one here
it's got what we call a persistent
lateral on it so we're going to get rid
of that persistent lateral we can leave
an extra bud there if we want to make
sure we get something in the space
although it's pretty long anyway so i'll
probably cut right about there
and that is how i would clean prune this
scott henry system so we'll come back
with some cane ties
tie those down
i've got my four cones i'll leave that
as a renewal spur and the vines done
ready to go once we tie it down for the
season
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu